hello everyone and welcome in chat how is it going warriors one in chat can you
oh look how many people
we're good we're good
two lost one win today says andrea we try to recover
uh there is also luca now guys i'm
i'm creating the avengers team okay all the best traders i know will be inside here
one of those is luca and uh they will participate in the battlefield chat so the lives are super
weak but you have the possibility to talk with other members and all the traders that are
profitable consistently profitable will be part of the group the group will be open tomorrow
and it will be you will see in the dashboard for everyone it will call battlefield right
now you have only battleground preparation during the weekend i was thinking it could be nice let me
share screen it could be nice to invite a nutritionist because some of you told me that
you want to know also for the supplements how to reduce the stress and how to deal with it because i
i cannot stress enough how much it's stressful this profession
grande luca anas made one to ten there is to reward you took the short from the top right anas
i was driving i couldn't take it i was driving back from the podcast business base is overcrowded
couldn't get the short but it was an amazing setup session we saw
a garbage market consolidation not moving and stuff anyway majority of you made money anyone that made
money in the last session text one in chat even with this garbage condition now look at this the
previous session without order flow if i only guess based on price action i will not be able to survive
okay because i will be not fast enough to put my stop loss to break even and we took
multiple break even made the most in my life trading in the last session nice arzalan
nice amazing amazing guys now can you see the screen can you see it properly
okay okay now what we're going to do today we are going to cover the mental models
that you need to use we are going to do live charting
and we are going to the execution method trick let me see the chat yesterday to micro from pop yesterday
oh nice one perfect rejection at the poc from 16 but i was delayed because of the profile amazing
amazing trade amazing trade so one other took the short youtube florin you took the same short that i
was taking before unfortunately i was not with my setup so i couldn't manage because i had the live
and it's not easy to trade and at the same time explain but amazing setup amazing setup now
i want to start with this it will cover not much not much time and we will treat this while we do live
charting i want to ask you something guys how many of you lost money not because of the model but for
inefficient uh mental resilience when you go and draw down because i want to tell you my story now you
see the now you see world champion for world cup 2000 execution 500 amazing you see me like trading and
doing 10 20 30 40 50 000 per day but before before it was not like this it was really different than this
and trading can get to your mind can get to your brain and when you manage personal capital that goes
above a threshold that it's a lot for you so for example it could be for you guys 100 000 for me it's
millions and when you go and draw down and you break the profit streak so for example let's say that
today we close a bad day okay we close three stop loss okay four stop loss it can happen it will happen
like okay when you have something like this the only thing that can save you from doing damage
it's your mental model it's nice that you share hardship as well no sugar coating or i don't care
about sugar coating the pill to make you think that it's easy no i promise you that i will be 100
transparent and i will be completely honest with you and i had upside and then i had downside during
my career okay it's part of the game and the moment that you need the mental model usually is
the moment where if you don't have it already set up with rules you will up your
whole account okay how many of you did big drawdown and damage not because of the strategy type one in
chat but because of the mental models going in three stop loss look at the chat look at the chat
okay what i'm telling you is human nature here there is no shame no one needs to be covered behind the
camera we are all the same and we do this for a living okay we trade now if you never did this
congratulations you are in the top one percent that are able to keep their mind under control when
they are floating numbers i was not like this i had to become like this okay so what i want to share with
you today to start is the first mental model that is process oriented so i want you to try to shift your
satisfaction from end of day result to end of day process what does it mean i have a model okay the
model is saying that i only enter in profile framing uh in in trend condition and i execute with big
trades perfect as soon as my process it's on point i'm not over trading i'm not doing stupid stuff i'm
not risking triple the amount i should if i close the day with negative x percent is still okay is it
clear don't worry you see how much we are fast after three minutes was available the recording the last
session you have you have always there okay this part here it's counterintuitive intuitive because we
as humans sit and i know that you all at this moment okay try to try to think about this the
session is going good i tell you one session that i had one month and alphago that was at the same time
funny and depressing so it was a long a super long bullish day on november and i started to load my
position okay i started to load my position and i took amazing one two three one two four one to five
with multiple trades so i build the profit for the day till 41 42 000 okay that for a single day even if
you are wealthy it's it's a large sum of money it's a personal account it's not proper so the moment you
withdraw it's in your bank account and you can spend it okay so so it's it's a lot of money what i did at
what i'm not shy to tell you is the following i built for the session here and the session exploded okay
you know what your brain is telling you you have 40 000 of profit here you respected the process and now
you have an amazing result so what i did in this case is assuming in my mind that considering that
was a bullish session we will arrive here we will continue so i start to mark on the charts level that
are higher why because i put in my mind the target of closing six figures in one day 100 000 okay you
know what happened that i loaded a gain position here okay risking part of the profit of this one the
market did like this i added and this nap back taking me in a streak of four stop loss before going
here and out of the 41 000 in profit only lost 15 000 in profit but if i was patient i would wait for my
setup instead instead of chasing the market i would have close probably 75 80 okay this part here it's the
mental model that you need to have because i'm telling you because already i saw other time uh two
only two people out of more than 400 people no 350 people only two people in the chat told me the last
time fabio uh i think you need to get exactly the level where you enter the target and the stop loss so
they took this as a signal service these people are not interested in learning they want to make
quick money following your process and they don't have the mindset to stay in this group okay they
don't have the mindset because if you are here only not to learn and not to be independent but you are
here to take some signals here and there yes you will pay out for the money that you you paid for the
service but you will not go anywhere the moment i start to i decide to stop the session you don't
make money anymore because you didn't understand the process okay so we everyone needs to agree that
we are here because i want to make you profitable on your own not with me always close to you enter here
close here enter here close here break even okay look at oran yesterday i was up then lost everything
because i was impatient only to see the market move exactly the right way once once the proper you see
yesterday unfortunately we didn't have a live because if we had a live and we see that the
market is not performing we stop okay you remember in the live session that we did with word of wisdom no
we took a crazy sniper 25 000 okay then the market was choppy same stuff okay these are conditions
that i don't trade usually but we are with trades we want to take and explain i will try even if i
will stop for the day back to 15 000. fabio but it's still an amazing day still probably of course
it's still profitable because we have an edge but we gave back 10 000 to the market it's not smart
okay
not smart at all i cannot see your image i know now out of this you need only three rules please
follow these three rules and i promise you at least you will survive if you are dumb you don't know how
to analyze you don't know how to take what i teach and bring this into an edge at least you will not make
damage to your account okay so first point
not end of the result end of the process second point
you pay emotional triggers
in dollars without discount okay the moment you are not suitable to go in market you had an argument
with your family you had an argument with your girlfriend you had an argument with your father
you stay out of the market there is no way around it okay the only time i lost more money than
expected in my life is the moment i had someone in my family that was not with us anymore okay i
traded i was angry i didn't care about what i was doing i lost triple the amount that is the maximum
drawdown not for the day but for the week why your mindset is the reason you click buttons the moment
you start clicking buttons for your mind because you have an emotional trigger you have no separation
line with between a gambler you are at the casino okay you are at las vegas trying to trade this is what
you are doing look in the chat i blew one account for this arguing with me okay perfect second point
third point
your personal account is your bullet and you have one okay you have one remember this the damage that
you make to your personal account the unsustainable damage that you make cannot be recovered by just
depositing back in the broker because you just admitted failure to burn an account you need to be
inconsistent in mental discipline mindset model and control of yourself you are inefficient you are not
made for this profession if you cannot control yourself it's better that you stay out okay and i promise
you i will not sugarcoat you will burn money if you are not capable of doing this now you have one bullet
shoot it in a way where you don't have the pressure to empty immediately your gun you have time
the market is open every day if we include crypto every day of the week
why are you running why are you trying to take five seven ten twenty five trades per day you will not
get rich today you will only make damage okay so i want you to go in this session with these three rules in mind
then we are all human we all make errors but please i'm responsible in this program i'm not only a teacher
i'm someone that is responsible to install in your brain a program that can save you from yourself
this is the difference between a teacher that sells you a course and a teacher that care that you can
survive in these markets because this is a battleground okay and the broker will not help you the market maker
don't care about you you you can go to die in some forest
will be interesting if you yes but bitcoin guys i don't use order from bitcoin i use on-chain analysis
let's go let's go to the platform
ah i want to ask you something in the previous year i made amazing results
also using the volume spread analysis that uses stick volume there is any one of you that is
interested in my volume spread analysis model for trading view because if yes okay i can create a
template for trading you where you have volume spread analysis that is not the same as order flow it's
it's another different type of analysis but we can explain okay okay i need to upload because it's
a private code i need to upload upload on trading view and next week you have it
it yeah it's good also for stock it's good also for stock let's go so we start with our amazing
template here and profile framing now going through profile framing let me remove one second the tpo
how is the session of today guys
how is the session of today previous value
previous value ah something there is someone that remember the level that i told you the 25 000
and 200 as the bottom level before accumulation this one was the pivot now they are building up we
saw the last time i don't know how many of you if everyone is present they closed the session of
yesterday bullish i took some long yesterday okay they closed bullish the cash session is bullish now
they tapped into the high and they rejected so the cash session opened with a strong aggression to the upside
as you can see here and now he's rejecting how many of you loaded short guys text you in chat
if you took a shot from here based on the failed auction look at you look how many people
you are still running short yes or no okay
what we can see here so this is the
this is the template that we use for triggers and we can see that there is a crazy absorption at this
horizontal level there is a crazy absorption at this horizontal level and when we go to the reason
why we go to the reason
of why the market didn't continue higher i gave you the tool to understand it can you see it or no one
in chat my my type of analysis is not subjective what i do can be done from any one of you okay because
it's visible it's visible this aggression of the buyers fading the top failing the breakout at top
something that we can see okay and we can also see the lock-in from the sellers where is the looking from
the sellers here now this is one pattern that i also want to cover today and i want to take one
minute to explain to you because it's one pattern that made me a huge amount of money during the last
year and is this one
let's say that you have an absorption here okay so you have a lot of aggressive buyers pushing
failing to break out the top okay so this one becomes a failed auction
okay perfect then when you have the first lock that this absorption is successful when you have an
aggression with aggressive sellers do you agree with me you have an aggression aggressive sellers
locking in the movement okay so we have absorbed buyers aggressive sellers with result we can take one
short the trade that in 2025 gave me the most amount of money is the test of this level
with the confirmation of absorbed buyers so try try to reason with me you have an absorption at the top
okay you have an aggression that is rewarded so these buyers no follow through the aggression rewarded and
the buyers again absorbed you have three order flow information going in the same direction this is what
i wanted to show you okay guys don't be afraid to ask it if it's not clear see it okay absorption at the top
aggressive sellers 165 contract really strong the market tried to break this level for i think 2000
contract total 1400 contract total fail always this is your opportunity to jump in with a super small
stop loss okay you can cover yourself above the area and shoot for a one to 4.5 guys there is someone type
three in chat that notice that this is exactly the same model that i used to take the trade of the
session of 50 000 on youtube absorption at the top aggression entering when there is aggression collapse
okay this is today this is today the session that i took on youtube was the the second of
uh december oh look at this can you help me guys to read this so we do some live reading
what is here uh you see look at the chat when i was explaining there is one guy that
saw exactly what i mean joan prange you executed exactly the trade that i was explaining
you executed exactly look at this absorption at the top again okay then you have
all this effort candle is rewarded so a huge cluster of aggression and absorption at the top amazing
i entered this short also amazing setup you you see that is it's a method
it's a method probably they squeezed this low probably they squeezed this low let me see if
there is also a momentum setup let me go here this is pretty empty it's not so much volume because
it's the london session probably they squeeze the low 25 500
let me see how is the rejection now you remember that in my live session uh what i was doing the one
it did is on youtube i explained that when you have an absorption and a strong move down the aggression
of the last sellers is your first point of interest so where they can go to try to reload and then you
need to see the battle here if they manage to break or not and the second one is the first aggression
point which one is the first aggression point it's this one okay it's all this area because it's from
here that the sellers got absorbed sorry the buyers got absorbed completely and the sellers took control
so they broke this level now where are we going we are going to the origin of the movement from where they
from where they rejected guys you remember this level why would you be able to mark this level by
yourself when you are alone when i'm not there will you be able to mark this level why try to explain to
me why in the chat there is damien that took long because this one is the most important absorption level
of the chart this is the most important one guys okay and the most important absorption level of the
buyer so where the buyers got destroyed on the way up is this one
now they are playing here now i i'm really curious to see what they do here what they do here this is
important is it is better to take the trade immediately from the absorption or from the
aggression so here if you have a level where to cover yourself that is this one you can already when
you see rejection you can execute but let's take this for example okay is this an absorption or the
buyers are still in control what is this at the moment till they don't break from the downside buyers
are still in control so probably they want to reach this level again you see that they are using this
as a stair aggression sellers rejected tapped into again and now you see what's happening they go here
okay they go back here here we can see if there is an opportunity of course we can see the volume bar
i put immediately you want a single bar the delta bar look how much effort look how much effort they put
okay look how much effort they put here and now you can see what a drying volume
now you can see a drain volume now tell me guys
is this precise is this precise or no look at the first rejection because the first rejection is
telling you if you mark level correctly it's the the capacity to identify resting orders then you can
see a lot of stuff you can see the inability of the buyers to break out for multiple times we only had
one test okay you can see if they lock in the movement so the aggression of the sellers control like
you need to have something like this you can use a lot of stuff but the ability to mark the level
it's based on the the the first time that the market reached it was the rejection
okay this one was the first level of the day that we marked we'll make it blue but it's
count unfortunately it's counter trend this one it's counter time this one
it's trend following
mamma mia
i cannot even watch the chart that immediately
will it be a squeeze if you break the green box guys from how how the price action is unfolding
i will not say that it's so smart to take along
yeah we can see we can see the downside pressure now you can understand that even this small movement
okay even this aggression of the sellers that you had here if you think about entering at the level
and closing above it's a huge risk reward what is this information what happened candle is closing like
this what what does it mean all these sellers got absorbed all of them
all these sellers got absorbed now what they try to do they try to reload here
they try to reload on the same level okay you know when you will have a good movement
a good movement you will have if we manage to break this law
if we manage to break this law we have a good movement
as always guys it's for educational purpose it's not financial advice
okay don't risk your money use it to study look again is is this precision
something that will make you satisfied of your level of knowledge precision on the down level
precision on the top level see how it rejects okay now if these sellers
push against this wall you have a movement that is interesting okay because all these aggressive
sellers gets a confirmation of the direction of their their positioning okay so they can load back
again and you can see a candle that gets populated by aggression aggression aggression aggression aggression
okay but you need to push the downside now they are fighting if the market bias today is long
we don't need to go higher from the value area law of yesterday this is only one model this is the
profile framing on the long term yes you can go long let's go on the profile framing and comment
this together okay what happened what happened here where is the value area law of the previous session
it's here okay they try to tap the top they got rejected tom do you agree with me that this rejection
is not a good sign is not a good sign and that the value area law is really far and they didn't even
reach the poc we have a little bit of space to retrace yes or no tom that's the point but your analysis is
correct like the value of the session is telling us that we go high okay the value of the session is telling us
that we go higher back on this level look again the third time now one two three four four time okay
remember that every time that you attack the level the level gets weaker because other orders gets filled
nice level with the naked poc yes a man
what is your smartest way to add position as entry point changes and you mind that taking a b a b a is
not a problem a b a is not a problem you see what i told you every time if you see that your level
is not holding and the sellers got absorbed like here for example this information what is telling you guys
this block here what is telling you
going up or no squeeze up or no
these buyers got rewarded the candle closed long we managed to break this level and we have a huge cluster
between here and also the downside area okay they are squeezing the top
okay now these sellers absorbed or no you see this is the pattern that i usually take the squeeze
is is this sellers absorbed or no
absorbed absorbed you see you see how the the market behave the sellers it's absorbed the buyers got
confirmed even if you enter here not here still an amazing run up you don't need to make one two
three one two four always let's see also the next level how it behave now they are testing here
what happened on the testing level there was a 97 sellers absorbed they put another 75 contract here is it
is it rewarded or no
no okay then
when you make
this framing of the area okay remember that also the small position
okay this one is a one two three point nine
if you go back to the top now we just tested again for the third time it's a one to five
okay covering yourself below the area this is the squeeze setup
you see how the market continuously tap into this cluster you see how we tap into a reload all this cluster
okay
it's where the market took a decision
and the decision that the market took
is it long or is it short this one it's another target one to five
one to four point nine at the third touch
okay the problem you know where is the problem when you try to make
the super sniper one to ten now this one is still not super long but
remember that the more you are greedy with your target
the less the probability that it get reached is look at this amazing lesson
the market show us live
mind blow clear guys
look here now
what happened here also let's see if there is another setup
not so choppy it's moving it's moving they tap into these 255 contracts
they tap into this but this one this one here
it's a trade that it's a little bit difficult to take because you have always also this inefficiency
okay now if you frame here 139 255 73 65 62 do you agree that if we if we need to
make an analysis only based on numbers the most important aggression of all this chart area is this 255
is this okay for everyone guys
number if we need to see
see everyone the same stuff i'm not thinking oh this level broke this one so i make a consideration
if i want to make it stupid simple
and i want to take only the horizontal level not about of absorption that we talked before that anyway
anyway sustain the price
anyway sustain the price and i want to see in this aggression which level is the most strong and is this
one okay and is this one and here you understand also the flexibility that you need to have
because we were short here the first time it took an amazing explosion down then it came back three times
but when the market tell you something like this and you continue to short it's your responsibility
because it's you that you don't care about making money you only want to be right
do you agree with me
okay now also for this setup you can decide to execute with a stop loss before the area with the
target here or you can go for the home run okay you can go for the long setup
up with a huge risk to reward but this one have a lower strike rate you will have around 30 to 35
win rate so you will see more red
640 we consider a stop area 640
640 if i need to go long term okay so you had two choice either you enter here and you take us a target
above the eye or either you try to shoot it to the next level and the next level that i can see is the
25 646.39 okay now what happened here they did they did a failed auction or they did a breakout
is this a confirmation of selling pressure or buy pressure
unfortunately failed auction and after the failed auction where they came back
they came back they came back to the same level that saw the sellers absorbed before let's do this
together okay let's do this together we take this we print it here okay and let's say that we don't have
the big trades we only have the fixed profile you see that order flow is democrat democratic we see the same
information all over together look at this delta delta where the market rejected first time here first
time here it's not magic it's orders there is no skill in what i'm doing there is only reading
10 000 account i don't think i would also be able to open the mini no i'm pretty sure so the only
opportunity you have is micro ala if with a 10 000 account but maybe it's smarter if you have a small
account a prop firm only micro yeah but still guys when you are in the learning process okay it's okay
what's the problem if you are learning you don't need to see the number you need to see the process
remember that in futures trading that is regulated market if you are good there are
millions of investors all over the world willing to give you money
yeah there are a lot of investors so you need to learn the skill you don't need to raise capital
by yourself what an amazing auction guys what an amazing auction today what an amazing auction
is respecting the level like crazy like crazy
that's what i'm doing starting with 10 000 market to get consistency and confidence then going to put a
couple hundred in once i'm profitable yeah i think it's a smart choice keep
i think it's a smart choice keep
now guys i think the first reaction we will see at this level 25 646. look at this gap look at this
small gap can you see it there is a small gap between these two candles if the candle close green is
shoot does and goes to the to the next level you see how they reload on the gap this is inefficient
volume because it created a micro gap
and when they go back here the market reload
nice one
really nice you see the first rejection when you get close to the level one okay how many of you took
the sniper guys and not only one one two three third test how many of you
uh hacks didn't took it amazing
ah you are still in roy going really high damian is ten thousand dollars in profit personal or prop account
four hundred dollars for rick i took three of them nice henry ftmo okay still money
tick by tick you have data on deep charts acts
i made four hundred dollars today personal nice armon
i've been with you since the boot camp i never thought i'd be this precise amazing another guy with another sniper
top step today was behind deep charts i was farming you are printing money amazing
so good now guys remove the long okay let's not consider the long i always think about the first touch
okay you see the first time they reach you see it's clearly visible the absorption it's visible that on
this level there are resting orders okay there are resting orders on this level now what happened that
usually you do reload on one level if you want to break so i would like to say some aggressive sellers that
get absorbed or seeing the price going back to this balance level price going back to this balance level
but these are counter trend trade and i don't like to take them i don't like to take them
they are really trying aggressively to break remember that this level is sustained by 39 250 89
around around 25 million of notional value okay and if this gets broken we shoot strong
we shoot strong up you have a squeeze okay you have a squeeze
look how much is beautiful
a squeeze guys is when you see a sudden acceleration so from here it jumped directly
maybe here with one single candle because there are a lot of closing of cell
unfortunately there is not a big participation from the aggressive buyers so big orders in this
movement the last loading they did it's here this is the last loading they did one two three four then
they stopped no now i don't see anything that we can execute buyers are scared now no it's not that
they are scary just that they are high in the curve you see here a lot of participation here a lot of
participation now there is a dry up in volume it's a little bit dry the movement but still when they go
back to this level i can see the buyers reloading you see they try to break three four five times and
they always hold this level that they broke it means that their intent is to go higher
okay their intent is to go higher i usually don't like to take trades when there is no support from the
aggressive order market participants but if you have other confirmation that you like to use maybe the
delta profile footprint you can do it
speed of tape is dry but i think it will get soon
soon interesting
because now you see oh you remember the last live that i showed you
look at the coherence you see that this vertical candle it's the one populated by this aggression of
sellers
it's the same candle and it's the candle that initiated all this movement this is what i was trying to
to explain the last slide that i gave you the model with deep trades plus the aggression candle of the
speed of tape this mean that is interesting is 681 a good tp where is 681 681 681
yes it's a smart tp but i don't understand why you are trying long in the no man land see that there is
nothing here okay the last opportunity that i see long is one and two that is the two that i told you
anyway now it will be so entering at this cluster
it's one two six entering with a really high stop loss it's a one to two point five still paying out
i took two now securing one hour
oh you took two one to one risk to reward it's it's still good yeah i know there is
perdming arzalan we will cover it don't worry i want to do some
charting because today he already gave us multiple opportunities that are amazing
see how they it's shy the speed of tape
speed of tape is shy aggressive sellers remember this level that i told you the one that they will
visit you see so now the speed of tape is loading now the speed of tape is loading and the speed of
tape look look look look at the aggression on the downside of the speed of tape
populated by
aggressive sellers and which is the level that stopped at least for the first time all this collapse
does it make sense to you that it stopped here with the week yes or no
it's not subjective
and look how much the market is amazing now the speed of tape of the buyers it's super aggressive
they are reloading to protect this level so they are fighting they are fighting in this area
against sellers trying to recover the aggression aggressive pressure that they put before
can you still consider to take different type of trades like momentum breakout when you are in a
whole balance space you can take yes but you need to be
not exactly at one level value area high or value area low because it's the probability that you will get
into consolidation because the aggressive orders meets the limit price wall on the top or on the
bottom is giving keeping you in consolidation this is the worst case that you can have for
uh a momentum trade
would you consider a cell continuation i will consider a cell continuation if we break out this level yes
if we break out this level yes
but this one for me this aggression that got absorbed here and this reclaim of the level that got
reconfirmed here it's a really good sign for the loan it's a really good sign and it's possible that
if we manage to recover this huge candle okay and we see i i don't ask a lot but a little bit of
participation of the buyer some big trades then we go to the target that the other guy said that
is this one so let me clean everything and only mark the sensitive areas that i'm watching sensitive
area one sensitive area two this is the absorption this is the intermediate area that we don't need
this goes broken this goes broken so we don't need this is the playground this is the playground
fabio will you consider shifting your view of course of course i will consider shift shifting my view
when the market tells me so if the market gives me an aggression on the downside that breaks this area
breaks this area and break this one i will say probably we now are ready
to attack the law and for attacking the law i mean attacking the 25 545
but as of now for example guys this one okay this pattern on the most important area that we saw
gives you the vibe of a rejection or a continuation short like will you short now yes or no
you can short now okay if the market gives you the breakout so if this candle boom aggressive here
you can take a short on the momentum phase but till the buyers are so aggressive here i think we tested
four times and each time they rejected we don't have the clue that the aggressive sellers are strong enough to
break okay okay we have the clue that buyers are protecting the level and they are doing this
amazingly because also the last test that they did here the sellers got completely absorbed
this is the intermediate wall that the sellers are putting
if this one gets broken expect volatility 25 632 if this one gets broken from the buyers expect volatility
and if you are waiting for a confirmation to get short wait for this level to collapse wait for it to stop
printing this week and to have a clean break
let's see how they behave
i cannot look at the picture and no because i'm watching chart
now another time they filled into the inefficiency also of the 139 executed contract and now i start to
see popping the speed of tape long can you see guys i don't know if it's big enough otherwise i can
amplify but you see that it's green this candle and this candle is telling you that the speed
of tape of the aggressive market order on the buy side it's interesting and it's always on the same
level it's always on this horizontal level now they are fighting this is an important decision level
you don't load your picture and no i only see a blank image
there is nothing
yeah they are defending
the buyers are defending
let's see where we are in location
we are a little bit below the value area i
a little bit below we are almost at the poc
they are really trying their best they are really trying their best to break it
and now the speed of tape you see is growing from the sell side one and two this speed of tape is
really high from the sell side i will be surprised if they don't break it now because it means that there
is a huge absorption wall from the buyers if they don't break with this speed of tape and with this pressure we reject
look how much look how much
this one considering all the aggression is matched only by this
yes of course we can go through it peter of course we can go through the deep effort now i want to watch
this interaction then then we go through the deep effort
really curious to see can you understand guy which level of a fight they are putting in here
which level of a fight on these three tick there is between buyers and sellers
and this is the moment where you risk slippage this is the moment where you risk slippage because maybe
you try to put your order here with a stop loss slide below the level gets broken and the candle squeeze really strong
because this this is a decision level
this is a really important decision level
they close like this with the speed of tape
so the sellers are in control
but if they break the level will become a cell protection level exactly jason you got the point
if they break it this level will be used to reload on the cell side
but if they break this level guys you will not see a small movement there if they break this level it's
it's explosion because all these buyers need to close you see look at here it broke it failed
every time they try to break buyers absorb look at the speed of tape and look how much they are absorbing
is it clear for you guys how much it's important the relationship between volume and price
if you see a lot of volume here but the the level don't break but it just print a week
it means that they put a lot of volume but they failed
okay look at how much they are fighting
sell control level buy control level
this is the final war they are they are putting billions here they are loading billions
and yes if this one breaks it's an amazing opportunity to go on the downside to the level
that we saw before the sensitive level that we saw before
they are trying their best guys
i understand the battle what is this biba
biba can you do can you ask the question again because i lost it and when i click it maybe i can
do like this no
i understand the battle look at the buyers look at the buyers look at the buyers
look at the buyers stand up a stand in italian means they are fighting to hell
uh here i understand the battle but i want to understand how they are
i want to understand how they are defending or protecting an area if the position were already open
does that mean they are reloading orders of course when they go here okay and you see that the market
goes here and then reject again it means that the passive orders are stacking liquid here so they
are absorbing all this cell aggression so the market is not having the cap is stopping here and they
are also loading long as you can see here beautiful beautiful beautiful
is it clear biba
does affect the defending zone when london is closing position
does affect the defending zone what do you mean i didn't understand put your name not user 015
put your name
and they didn't manage to break we still have only two important level
we still have only two important level the aggression of the buyers and the protection level of the
buyers here they put a flag and the level of the sellers we have these two
still true then if you break this
you have this level that it's really interesting
nothing else it's not necessary to mark intermediate level that are useless for us
no i don't think it's uh it's lagging i see that the connection is going right and you don't have
even delay in the live can you hear me properly can you see my child look here
look at this aggression of the sellers can you hear me properly
i see the chat
not going so i think it's my problem now
chat in pausa casa dello scorrimento ah now yes okay the chat was post now guys chat
what is this it's giving you an additional information or no
oh and these buyers at the top
so the candle closed green with sellers absorbed at the bottom and buyers at the top
what is telling us
he's telling us that the buyers look here again
someone is willing to buy at the top
and the result of the buyers
how is the result of the buyers at zero
and the result of the sellers zero we are stuck we are inside this range we can make the range even
more precise but it doesn't change anything this is the range
usually what i like to do in this situation is stacking it's waiting and stacking one order
that is capitalizing on the explosion of the range okay so when you have a clean control point
stacking an order okay and for control point i mean you need that to have an acceptance of this
okay so some big trades here at the top or clean breakout and test and we are stacking our third position for the day okay
i got this one running with small risk from the fair value gap protected by 400 buyers
nice one hey it's the one that we saw before
we will watch fundamentals later if you want if we want we will watch
if we want we will watch fundamentals later
it's not necessary now the deep effort because we are watching the interaction from the big orders
cvd is telling you buyers more aggressive let's see you see that in this case they created a breakout
of the movement they try to test the level and when they try to test the level they are still stuck here
okay so you don't see other participation from the big trades this is an important information okay
is telling you that yes the buyers are interested but there is not follow through on the auction so
the direction is still not decided okay because if the direction was decided you will see aggression
aggression aggression like here bam bam bam bam bam okay it's clear the direction for me because the
structure is unfolding on the upside and we have this absorption so it's clear to me that we are going long
but we don't see participation of the big so maybe this target is too long it's too on the upside that's
the reason it makes sense to put the risk to zero on the upside to risk zero so we are not even using the
profit of the previous one and then considering to run through the final target there is a bigger movement
and how are you scaling when you are right uh i explained this multiple times but if you want to
met uh when this now i want to see the how with the price action unfold and the volume unfold when we
finish showing this one remember that we need to see position management two we need to see the third
model four we need to see three sorry we need to see the deep effort remember for me
guys what i told you when you exit from a compression phase you have momentum okay look at this single
candle look at this single candle how much it's aggressive how much it's aggressive this single candle
so what they told you buyers stuck at the top seller stuck at the bottom result of the buyers confirmed
and now the market is coming to test okay it's closing an inefficiency touch the level and close the
level with this absorption so this one here would have been your filling point
this one would have been your filling point look at this aggression of the sellers speed of tape
speed of tape the sellers are loading new position even if the buyers are protecting now sellers
are stronger so what does make sense on this position to consider covering okay covering your risk when
you go out of the level so considering that the sellers are being absorbed and the buyers are being
followed up you can also go risk-free if you enter precisely really fast okay so considering that when
you clean this level and to clean this level i mean breaking the stock for example you can go risk-free
because if it breaks on the downside even now if it breaks this level the analysis invalidated so you
go to stop loss let's see how it goes now they are engaging again sellers and i want to ask you something
guys how is this interaction of buyers and sellers see one minute risk-free is it amazing this trade
management or no now ignore it goes to profit it goes to stop loss but how much is precise
we mark the level from before we know exactly where there is the high probability of rejecting and we
have time to go stop-losing at zero so fast not even one candle it's better to take three break even
four break even that losing money hey you see here when to enter you see this uh absorption in one candle
you have two following absorption then you have an aggression here
they teach the opposite everywhere else nick and this is the reason people lose money
let's make a survey please be honest be honest okay don't be afraid to tell no it's garbage what
you teach okay how many of you were losing before or struggling and are seeing consistent results the
first time one in chat okay i cannot fake the opinion of people i cannot fake the opinion of people there are
hundreds of people in the chat what a sniper guys this one what a sniper what an amazing sniper
ah look how they they they enter someone is making one to four
oh the price action it's a little bit choppy you can also decide we took two one two three okay you can
also decide look you know what i take another one two one point five here i close like the other
session no two one two three six r plus 1.5 you close 7.5 and you are done but the confidence of
going to break even when the market tell you that you can go because anyway if it breaks this level we
go down it's something that is keeping you it's keeping you safe
and but you are not uh risk free mario you are still with position in the market be careful
oh now let's go here what the market is telling us what the market is telling us
the aggressive sellers are slicing through the aggressive buyers okay where is the first level
where they find difficulty in going down the one that we marked
when you start to see this in 3000 setup like i did on the world cup 2300 you start to understand
that there is a big difference between skills and probabilities okay
this information here can say you know what oh i take also a little bit of money out of the market
maybe it's not much it's 200 dollars but better in our pocket than in the pocket of the market makers
better like this
no no no it's not delayed guys i don't do delayed live
it will be easy to pretend that i'm precise with delayed live it's for fake gurus this is real time
and you can check with your chart
important level yes here you will take out your take profit your partial your first take profit look
at the rejection and the precision on the level
look at the precision of the level
look at this
just past five evaluation account bravo fabio no bravo to you
bravo to you just giving you my view
later we go to to the cot florian for now the profile is long
how do you manage your day if you started with a loss
if i start with a loss i continue till three if i reach a maximum of three stop loss either i lower
the exposure but usually i stop for the day but guys it's really difficult for me to take three
stop loss in a row it's really difficult it happens two or three times per month but it's not common
and not because i'm precise but because my my position management
it's fast so if i take a break even it's not a stop loss
the market only takes the commission out of me
okay so it's it's not a problem it's not a problem at all
no i'm expecting a final target here
expecting a final target here
one day it will be nice to see how you actually execute and manage your trade i add a huge amount
of content maybe in the next life when we have a chat that is less demanding i can do it
yeah also with reads
also with reads you need it's really difficult to talk and trade
while you analyze execute manage see the chat let people understand it's not easy nice trade oh you
trade on interactive brokers also okay then i can recognize
yeah you only make money
you only execute
how did i mark this level based on this
you see
how many in the chat can understand why this level it's important for me
why this level it's important
this level is the starting of the cell move participated by the aggressive cells but it's the
huge absorption look here this cluster it's incredible this is the initiation of the move
the
no i don't uh i don't notice the shape of the candle like the pattern guys you know i have a theory i can
share with you okay the theory my theory is the following
that the trading industry is controlled
by
multiple educators okay
that pretend to be
to write books about useless stuff like technical figures pennant
cap and dandle and stuff that doesn't work and it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy you know
because the beginners advise this book to other beginners and everyone study the same
bullshit but when you do this from a quantitative perspective you understand that 95 percent of the stuff that they teach you don't work
okay
and it's not fabio saying it
like if if you try to make money and i should risk
two thousand three thousand dollars five thousand dollars per position based on one shape
okay of i don't know cap and dandle
i will be scared as
fuck
fuck guys
so jay i have some students that scalp gold also that trade gold also and they have amazing result
with my momentum model and my models that i use on nasdaq i don't know if there is luca in chat luca are
you in chat one in chat franceschettis one in chat if he's here
he told me that the model works amazingly also in uh in gold
i do usually the minute or the range the range when the market is choppy look at this
when the market is getting in a choppy mood you can use the 40 range it's still the same visualization
but you see how much it's uh
it's less crowded so you don't have candle on top of candle on top of candle it's more
and specifically the speed of tape it's more relaxed more clean on the range but the analysis
is the same you see sellers absorb at the bottom sellers absorbed at the bottom sellers absorbed we
are recovering
okay guys if you decided to not take take profit here and to until here you can also manage like i
do the position you manage the position with a stop loss in profit here okay so you are already
taking out a one-to-one you have additional r and remember that the market is here for you so if you
get taken out it goes back to this level you see another you can take another trade look it's here
how does it work the model for gold luca
okay so you trade i know why luca is not replying look how much money are you making scalping the long
send send send your chat distracted this guy yeah beautiful
nice making money money there
buyers at the top everyone in profit
everyone in profit
still in the game
rick took
600 straight on five account look look at these guys look at these soldiers
i heard that people participate in training tournament increase the risk per trade but how
do you do do you keep your 0.25 so you know what i do i stack profit for the day using it
to risk another trade let's say for example i take three take profits
after i take three take profit at the next trade it's part of the profit i made
you go heavy yeah you trade almost as many contracts as me
me nasdaq for start it's okay guys you need to learn the process
you you need to learn how to cover yourself and the process
you want me darko to after we finish to see this trade to give a breakdown of the reason why i
explained this long this three long that we saw why why they take profit you want me to make a
summary for everyone from the profile framing to the session we can do it just wait one second
because i want to see if it fill this level and reject take one glass of water guys
it's amazing you're doing really well
doing really well now you see how i also trade my position when i'm really close to target is
trailing on the big trade so let's say that i have a stopping profit i put below the big trade on this
downside because i'm happy with uh one to three instead of a one to three point six
okay but i'm not happy if the market touch this level from here and collapse down and sometimes
when you are really good at framing the areas it happens so now the price completely are
is sustained by this demand created by the 65 contract let's see how it goes
you saw me in the live like trailing here then you have an aggression trailing here then you have
another aggression the 50 000 session i did exactly like this
i don't use the b tracker layer so i cannot help
you see how we're starting to reject the top
here you are out you are out with your one to 2.7 one to 2.6 if you stay in the long term
you see the market went down absorbed and probably you go to the full target
one two three how many of you took the full target guys look at the rejection speed of tape
they are trying to break one in chat fabulous trade you know what is fabulous but we are not
inside from here here we are inside from the beginning of the move with this precision
amazing amazing today three target
and look at this wait wait it's not finished look at this
because knowing where it's better to remove your position is part of the the game knowing which level
can create your problem
it's okay jason it's okay learning is more valuable than making more money but i want to know if it's
clear if you understood everything that we did
what information is giving you the market here
the buyer set the top on the level that we saw with an absorption
speed of tape long so they will try to reload that they will try to break this level okay now
let's go on the profile framing first of all the value
that we are building so this is session one
this is the session of yesterday
and this is the session of today
the profile framing is long or short
it's long okay perfect we started with the rejection of this so it means that they tap into the high
of the previous session they rejected and we were here what i was trying to take and to capitalize
is the virgin poc test okay so i was trying to take this
to do this
in line okay this one the market did a retracement
and then decided
not to go to the bottom as a matter of fact the first level that we mark for the day you remember
this one is the bottom of the day
when we start alive please watch it i mark this level explaining why it's really important but this
buy was counter trend because at this moment sellers were still in control okay here and here but after this breakout
look at this aggression there is no doubt from here take together these three information chat
the behavior of the sellers here
okay that we saw live and they let you participate in what they were doing the behavior of the buy here
what they are telling you is the following let's remove all of this
okay and let's do like this so the profile framing is long
we are here and we expect a long okay the sellers are in control they find a level a wall
the sellers reload and they expect they to try to break this and they tried two times but then
unfortunately they broke how they broke with sellers absorbed and buyers rewarded you understand that now
the more probable scenario is this and i didn't created this based only on profile framing but i watched
the live interaction between buyers and sellers if here let's make an example here if here
we have this absorption okay of the buyers and then we have aggressive sellers aggressive sellers
okay and we break this movement okay would have been a continuation because the sellers had enough
strength to break but considering that they tried they failed they retraced they tried again you can
see their attempt here they tried guys they tried their best they failed and i was watching here maybe they
try again no broken from here there is no short opportunity that makes sense from this moment i only told you
also when it was unfolding and printing momentum trade and it will have been an amazing risk to reward
also after the test then we took the reload zero drawdown and shoot up and where is rejecting now at the final target
amazing satisfied with the sauce that you bring home today we go to the third model
this is the final target not of the day is the final target for the position okay because this is the most sensitive
level but there is no reason why they will not break this level if your approach is not to be based on
one level to the other one two three one two four one two five and i'm out but your approach is
i want to take the full movement of the session then your target will be this huge absorption at the top
this will be your target okay you know why i don't trade like this because it's really frustrating for me
when you are floating 10 20 30 000 and then you want to shoot for more and it comes back it's really
frustrating for the way i approach the market to see all this profit back to the market i prefer to make
three four ten thousand dollar of trade uh making a total of 40 000 that's making one big shot of 40 000
that after three hours i mean reverse and i see from 40 to zero this one drives me crazy i cannot accept
it is it's bad for my mental health and it's not scalable i think i don't like it
yeah but this is personal opinion this is personal opinion so the big trades guys are
60. the filter it's on 60. and you know what one time frame that i'm loving recently that is based on
range is the 80 range it's really clean look how much it's clean absorption at the bottom now you
know what is beautiful about volume every single time frame is confirming all the setup that we took
from point of view of volume absorption at the bottom buyers aggressive at the top this was our
trade they came back to test huge absorption at the bottom buyers in the body another explosion absorption
at the bottom buyers another explosion okay this one was absorption at the top sellers and we could
expect that from here we will go down that's the reason we take partial and then the buyers
absorb sellers aggressive buyers here when we have the first sign of weakness you see it it's visible
i can go on 80 range i can go on 40 range i can go on one minute is it visible
yes does this mean that we are going short for all the session no but this means that i found a wall
here there is a wall and this wall got identified to us before to not risk that the market there can do
this and reject okay if this wall gets broken where can we go we have already the level ready okay it's
this one this is the level okay so now what the market is doing if you want if you are not happy with
the trade that we took and you want to do another trade okay what can you see aggression and absorption of
the sellers no this means that if this level gets broken this one
you can have something like this
test
i mark this one two on the right wait a second so breakout
test probably on the absorbed sellers like this and then you can consider a follow-up but you need
to have this breakout because otherwise this one it's a standpoint of control of the sellers and we marked
the first one
okay
of course i can repeat let me go to the so the three main catalysts that i watch
are the following first i need an area
that i can qualify
from one profile framing so it can be the value area i the value area low or the poc okay so it
can be a sensitive area from the profile framing perspective the second reason i can do this is
based on the observation of order interaction using the trades okay so let's make an example
i have here an absorption that is so strong of the sellers for two times straight okay this is a strong
by area for me okay this is a strong by area this horizontal area even if i'm closed inside this
range this one for me it's a strong by area if i am here and i see the result with this aggression
this is a strong by area for me if i'm here and i see the absorption this is a strong by area for me
okay
so
i can use this to qualify my area and i will make you some example
if here i have a consistent absorption of aggressive by orders
on the top okay i have either the fading
reversal so you want to be a sniper and you want a system that is sustainable to be a sniper even if
your win rate will be lower you trade the fade with a stop loss above and you try to take the beginning
of the move for a huge risk to reward okay you want to be someone with high win rate like today
then you can trade the confirmed fade setup and what is the confirmed fade setup is that you wait
for the aggressive sellers to take control of the movement that you qualified so you had a distribution
okay you had control of the sellers you mark this area
and then you engage okay and then you engage and the third one
way to qualify area is using the delta profile from fixed range
what you are explaining it's happening right now from our area
this is a reload like i told you this is a reload to go by
this one this one here it's a reload this this between this area you have this absorption okay
and you have this absorption of the buyer so what can happen is the same as before
i will mark for you i will not take other trades okay because we already took amazing setup for today but
let's say that you want to trade because you want to trade okay it's the same setup as this one you see
sellers at the bottom absorbed sellers at the bottom absorbed buyers at the top absorbed buyers at the top
absorbed perfect breakout of compression phase test with aggressive sellers skyrocket to the moon
can you see it can you see it the coherence between these two setups
what's the only problem of this setup that you are really close to the wall it's not a smart setup that's
the reason i will not consider it you are so close to the wall and some of you will say yeah you are
close to the wall but if you break this wall you have the momentum and i cannot say no it's right
if you manage it's lower probability but if you manage to push this level you have an aggression that is
interesting okay you have an aggression that is interesting now going back to what i was explaining
this one is the safe setup the confirmed faith setup okay the faith setup it's having as i told you 35
to 40 percent but with a lot of risk reward okay and there is also a fourth way to qualify the area
where you can execute from that is the origin of the move using price this one i keep in my heart
from my price action era and is still working in an amazing way okay why because let's say that you
want to use you come from price action and you love price action so you get good at trading
price action so you say fabio i want my perception model but i want to execute this in a precise way
what can i do you can reason in the control area what do i mean control area i will give you an explanation
let me draw draw here and i will explain to you okay
okay okay okay now what does it mean controlled area is the study of the area that is controlling price
now let's make an example this supply
is controlling the price okay till we don't break it this demand is controlling the area till we don't break it
when can i say that this demand it's more important than this supply when this level
gets broken
when this level gets broken the supply it's meaningless so i have only this demand in control
this areas usually give you an amazing setup when you pair with order flow maybe it's an absorption
maybe it's an exhaustion okay let's make another example
this supply area it's interesting till the moment i don't break it when i break it my demand
takes control okay here
when i break this consolidation phase my demand gets control so everything that happened here in control
from the buyers momentum setup i can bring up when is that i have a flip when i have a supply here i
have a demand here and this demand gets broken so you have control of the supply
and they will continue to have control of the supply as much as the structure is telling me
that the sellers are in control okay with a personal
care to take out part of my profit on this area because i can reverse okay but with a confirmation
that the sellers are in control till i don't break them and when i break them when this demand
creates this breakout and now i'm controlled from the buyers and when i break this becomes the demand so
i can continue to search long okay is it clear guys one in chat when you have this you can say i
continue to take short in this in this behavior i continue to take long in this behavior i continue
to take long in this behavior as always you will have some stop loss but they are part of the game
part of the game what happened here what happened here guys
demanding control still a garbage area because they are closed inside this range
okay but look at this the area that i marked for you again for the fourth time today rejected amazingly
buyers i explained to you what when we break this we test they tested yes zero draw look at this guys come on
look at the control point they take when you have this pattern
i repeat for you you are long of bias okay start to notice absorb sellers buyers at the top breakout and
testing with absorption on the bottom
okay now can you understand why we are having some resistance here yes or no
remove everything watch only here i gave you the tools to understand this by yourself
okay
here it's not interesting for me all this area is not interesting but here
we have a lot of absorbed buyers this means that this level for sellers is interesting
and guess what will happen if the buyers take control also over this level
that we skyrocket here
no way around it we squeeze it
no way around it we have a lot of people who have a lot of people who have a lot of people
they what do you mean uh rick confirmation on close
the level that they closed above was this one like the setup that we saw before
this one okay absorption at the bottom buyers at the top you break and you test zero drawdown okay this
one is the same what you add you add absorption at the bottom buyers at the top test what we miss
we miss the aggressive sellers they didn't do and i think they can come back i think they can come back
print aggressive sellers and then go out let's see
it will explode up it will explode if they break this they need to break this
if they break the top for example when you want to understand
how much pressure there is you can also see the cumulative volume delta
the delta candlestick
what is this telling you they are still loading they are continuing to load they are already above the top
with the cvd they are already above the top it means that they are continuing to load you see they
broke from the cvd point of view
can you see here okay and what it's incredible it's incredible that now they have a cvd cell candle but
the candle is printing green so they are absorbing with passive liquidity all this attempt to go short
and this is interesting because it means that even if they are at the top of the range still there
are buyers absorbing absorbing absorbing seems like an accumulation you see how they start they restart
from here
and this is not common why it's not common because we are in a wall so i would expect sellers to take
control okay i will not expect that candles that have all this delta close long if this happen it means
that the buyers are putting back again passive order wall and they are pushing the auction down
okay they are pushing the auction down they are absorbing look at this horizontal level that we saw before
it is a big gamma level where we are and the one right above and this is the reason they don't manage to break it yet
okay they are not having an easy time breaking it and for the fourth time they got rejected
on the level
hey
okay
I'm not watching Gamala, it's just I am.
Is I am the guy that is texting me every day?
Is it you, I am?
I don't remember all the name, guys, sorry.
Buyers are sleeping.
Guys, but you cannot expect always action.
You need to build some patience.
It's normal that you have some consolidation.
To give the market the possibility to have trend, you need to wait for consolidation.
Just one second, guys.
Is that...
Fabio loading.
No, no, no, I'm not loading, guys.
I'm solving...
Cache, I was trying to hide that I was loading, but it's visible.
No, I'm playing, I'm playing.
Look at this absorption.
Rick, I feel that my trading is getting consistent.
I just want to say big thanks.
I will get to Dubai and make coffee.
Yes, let's go.
A good Italian dinner, guys.
Should we do a meetup in Dubai at the end of the year?
Should we do a meetup in Dubai?
Nice.
Let's consider it.
At the end of the last quarter, Dubai.
Look here.
What you notice, what you notice, what you notice, watch fast, fast, fast, fast, fast.
What you notice between these two candles?
Inside the area, there was so much bullish pressure that they gapped.
And what I always tell you about the gap, that is really important, the candle next, because
if the candle next rebalance the gap, now they rebalance, and close green, okay, so they
rebalance and reject, and you have a good movement.
You have a good movement up.
Violent one.
If the candle hit the gap on the downside, so it hit the gaps till the beginning of the move, then it got completely absorbed.
All with NASDAQ cap.
Okay.
How the candle is closing, guys?
The candle closed purple, and what happened?
The market pushed down.
Look at the delta.
Bam.
Now, all this aggressive sell, all this pressure, got confirmed or absorbed?
I know that it's fast at this time, but you need to notice what happens.
All this delta.
Absorption or long?
Absorbed.
I think we continue long, guys.
I think we continue long.
I marked this level.
I'm really curious to see.
They didn't yet rebalance the beginning of the level that is this one.
We don't have much level that are interesting for us, so we have...
This has a decision level from the downside, and this level for a potential upsqueeze.
We have one here, and we have all this area here.
Now, if we want to mark using the profile, we can do like this.
Oh, it went back to the level.
Wait, wait, it's too fast at all.
It went back to the level.
This is the level that we marked.
Imagine, guys, imagine now.
He print this aggressive absorption, and it goes long.
Like he did here.
Exactly like he did here.
Just for the sake of making sure that the setup is complete, because he missed the aggressive order.
We have news in five minutes.
Let's see.
With 30, you have more possibility.
With 60, you have less possibility.
It felt this level in a crazy way.
In a crazy way.
Now, I'm really curious.
Do you consider to lower the value of BT?
No, there is volume still.
77 here.
Speed of tape was so big.
I can see from the CVD.
I can imagine.
Look at this movement.
But you know why they are preparing, guys?
Because there is volatility in four minutes.
What news there is?
Can you check for me?
Which news there is in a few minutes?
10-year tip auction.
Okay.
Really curious to see what they do.
They tap into the buy area that we saw.
And now, what do you notice when we are getting close to a news?
You notice how many big trades you see.
Like, we had 30 minutes without participation.
And now, we have three big trades in two candles.
It means that they are fighting here.
It means that they are fighting like crazy.
Okay.
And when there is a news, guys, it gets heated up, the situation.
Let's try to read this mess of big orders.
So, the sellers...
I remove this, otherwise we cannot understand.
Okay.
The aggressive sellers control the situation from this big order here.
The big order got broken or is still valid?
This aggressive seller here.
Broken or is still valid?
It's still in control.
Still valid.
Okay.
This seller...
...is absorbed.
Okay.
And we are coming from a multiple hundreds of absorption here.
What does it mean?
That the battle to the side is in these two areas.
Okay.
The extreme one.
And the news is giving the burst of volatility to let you understand what they want to do.
Okay.
I'm on BS short.
You took the short from here.
This was the only short area that we saw.
But, you know what, Leonardo?
I will...
I'm really happy if you go short.
Okay.
If it goes short.
So, you make money.
But, I will not consider a short here for only one reason.
The auction.
The auction is still long.
Okay.
I prefer not to go opposite to the direction of the bias.
Of course, if we break this level, I change my mind.
But, I want to see the market before breaking.
Okay.
It's coming.
The volatility burst, eh?
Look how much is moving fast.
We need the speed of tape.
They are trying the hell to break this level.
Speed...
of tape.
Let's check with these guys.
How is it going?
So, the speed of tape is crazy in this movement.
And, it's building up on this way.
And, you have absorption on the buy side.
And, confirmation on the downside.
Now, we see how this candle closes.
Okay.
If this candle gets completely rejected, then, in this case, we can have a move up.
But, this candle needs to be completely rejected.
And, if it gets accepted, it's a squeeze on the downside.
This is the cluster.
This bit of tape, it's interesting, eh?
This bit of tape here, it's interesting.
And, you want to see how the candle closes.
You just want to see how the candle closes.
You don't want to execute.
You want to understand when you have a moment where the dominance is completed.
So, you have a clean part that is dominating the auction.
When this candle is almost closing, if it closes with the speed of tape,
heating up this and this, what do you see?
Long or short?
Eh.
You see, long.
Let's see if it closes.
And, you have...
Here we go.
You have the last trade of the day.
Let's see if it tests.
I will go for the last one.
Another 1-2-3.
The last 1-2-3.
And, we close.
Like, how many are we did today?
We did...
Three trades.
One was...
I don't remember, guys.
How many are we made?
On average.
Hey, it broke, but was a fake out.
It didn't...
It didn't complete the breakout.
That's the reason I always tell you, wait for the close.
Because it heated with speed of tape and aggressive.
6R.
Amazing.
Let's see if it tests.
I also want to show you the deep effort.
Now, I will show you.
Let's see if we get filled.
Yeah, of course it's possible, Tal.
This was the line point of...
The last point of aggression of the sellers.
I'm really curious to see if they hold the ground or not.
In the meantime, that it unfolds...
Ah, look here, eh?
Look at the speed of tape, but look at this rejection.
This is your level.
Oh, they are fighting like hell on this horizontal level.
The speed of tape, it's incredible.
If they break this level, guys, it's probably that they will never test here.
We didn't got filled for like one tick.
They are breaking.
It's not valid anymore.
I tried to make another last sniper.
But we didn't got filled.
Okay, I can go now on the...
I want to show you the deep effort.
To go on the 40 range.
Hey, if I didn't get filled, yes, because if it comes back, it breaks me.
So, it's not so interesting.
So, if I don't get filled, I remove the order.
So, let's go on the deep effort.
This one is interesting because it shows you who is in control at the moment.
And you can see from the deep effort.
No, don't tell me that it's filled me with this candle now.
It will be really fun.
It means that we are too precise for this game.
I think it was here, right?
I don't remember.
But you see, it just came to fill just to make sure that the community gets inside.
We removed anything anyway.
But it's good that we removed because you see that this one.
Do you like it or not?
This one.
Not so beautiful.
But anyway, let's go here.
Because this one, it's showing you, this is deep effort.
It's showing you who is in control.
You see, they show you it's control of the auction buyers, control of the auction buyers.
Who is controlling the auction now?
Yeah, it's like a wall.
It's like a wall.
It's like telling you that the buyers are in control of this movement.
So the probability, instead of breaking this level, is that we tap into top.
Okay, so that we have an extension here.
An expansion, sorry.
Breaking this level and potentially reaching also the final target.
Where was that?
I want to see the most important cell level.
You see, this one is not so strong.
It didn't even got marked, this absorption.
Guys, I just noticed that I'm live from 2 hours and 10.
Are you sure that you are not getting bored?
Seems like 15 minutes to me.
Let's go, let's go.
You can also pair them.
So now that you know that this level is controlled by buyers and you have a control of the buyers,
you can put this one and see, okay, now I expect a surge of the buyers.
Oh, today it's with the remote control of the market.
I say, you do.
I was saying, you need to wait for a surge to go to the next level.
Beautiful.
Now we touch the top range.
And it seems really aggressive to break it.
Guys, if this will have filled us on the downtick, it will already be 1 to 1.5.
Look at this.
Look at this bit of tape.
Okay, calm.
Because there is a huge volatility now.
Calm.
319 absorbed orders and 1.04 on the bottom.
They skyrocket.
Mark this level.
Here they want to mark this horizontal level.
What a beautiful session today, guys.
All this speed of tape down and everything got absorbed.
Now they are coming to rebalance on the 319.
Of course, I removed.
But if you got filled here, go risk-free, eh?
Go risk-free.
Don't give back not even $10 to the market.
You did a crazy sniper.
Don't let this volatility take you out with a spike.
If it goes, it goes.
This is not the delta.
It's the speed of tape.
Martin, he's loading and then posting news.
Leonardo, I really would like that you go to profit on the short side.
But this, it's really risky.
Because this absorption of the sellers means that there is a liquidity wall here.
And if this high gets broken, we really skyrocket.
If we break this down on the other side, we go down heavy.
So if you are still short anyway, you could go risk-free.
Because you have an amazing standpoint here.
You are short from here.
Zero drawdown.
So either you are short, either you are long.
It's good to take a risk out of the market when the situation is so heated.
Because you can get a slippage.
Now, guys, I want to show you something.
I remove this one second.
And I show you only the balls.
The one on the chart.
Don't dream.
This.
Okay.
Now, let's go here.
This aggression, 319, this aggression, 104, and this breakout of the level.
What makes you think?
I say in this chart, I didn't have the time to say it makes you think long.
Makes you think an aggression.
Okay.
Now, if they manage to break this, no?
If they manage to break this, you agree with me that all the sellers that are stuck
and all these absorbed buyers need to be released.
And if all these huge amount of buyers need to be released, this movement is fast.
Okay.
This movement is fast.
Let's see how they go.
So they are tapping into these balls.
Trying to break again.
Let's extend the area.
You see how many times they try to load and break these two clusters.
They have two purple clusters.
The 104 and the 300 that are standing still.
Really curious to see if they manage to break or if they continue to do this dance of initiative auction and absorption.
Leonardo, you are making profit on this short.
Still inside?
See, either they reject on the 3.19 or the 1 on 4.
And they always dance here.
The buyers on the other side stopped participating 10 minutes ago in the play.
I can imagine Leonardo's emotion.
Yeah, but the delta is not the all-important stuff, Jersey.
You need to pair delta with the result.
Because delta is the input.
But then you need to see what the candle does.
Okay.
leonardo say fabio let it go today it's all break even but because you try to short the up move
yeah you are good tom
you are good you are good
on the ring chart is show bots i really let's watch it oh you're right you see now the
the nasdaq effort is telling you look you have the regression up the area on the upside but there is
a wall here so there is an obstacle to go up and this is the best behavior before a squeeze
this is the best behavior before shooting up the moon i like this
buyers are trying to load heavy
now we are on the top of the range the deep effort is a proprietary study and is based on the thickness of
the book so he's watching the number of effort that is necessary to move the price and when it's
really easy for one side to move the price and print the area so smart guys so smart this is like the
the concept of uh fluid dynamics okay the more is difficult to move something the more strength you
need okay and in this case we can apply this to price to market because if for volume the path of
risk resistance it's on the on the upside like we had here you see what it did it printed this candle
and it never came back now on the other side this red area that i marked for you is where the path of
risk resistance is on the downside so from this area the sellers are in control now if you want to
have a no-brainer ping-pong between these two areas pay you a lot of money pay you a lot of money
yeah i think depending completely on one indicator it's not what you want to do
because guys we are here to get freedom we are here to get possibility to be independent no
and but i don't talk only about something from me i talk about everything if you need something
to be profitable i don't want to say that you are slave of the tools but almost okay that's the
reason i want you to understand volume 360 every tool okay also the vsa to be able to read it with
anything in front of you we are going back to the to the area we are going back to the
buy control area just touched just touched let's see what they do now that we are inside the area i
want to see but you see guys how much these are precise anyway this printed we have a bottom this
printed and from here they did the high oh let's go here
uh this one i didn't saw why you didn't send me guys look at this amazing absorption at the top this
is the first time buyers participated and got completely absorbed this is a strong wall
this is really a strong wall robin said uh you see
thank you robin so it was my fault was replying and i didn't saw
michael is saying i always get stopped out i don't know this just so rough for me i never catch a move
michael which kind of trades for example today you took you took this one
you took this one or this test to the 255 if yes yeah go jason thank you for staying here
if yes here for example or here or on this test where did you got stopped out you trailed your stop
you took the short on open and made a lot but all the trading after the low i didn't trade well why
michael what have you done so you took an amazing show on top of the amazing trade we took you took
also this short during the open how is it possible that that you gave back this money to the market you
took this short if i understood right this one this incredible short stay with me one second michael
you took this short where did you close this short it varies from trade to trade richard
good question i show you immediately let's say that you are here okay and you want to risk
the same amount always on the single trade okay you open this you go on settings
you go on stop and you put 2500 okay
you like this
okay and it doesn't matter where you put you see that it's always 2500 2499 it's just changing the
contract i have to put seven mini contract here if i want to do this i have to put 15 if i want to risk
two thousand and five hundred if i want to enter here to take this i on this and having a stop here i
can risk six contracts 6.5 contracts
okay
amazing michael today the market only went up and we managed to take all the long on the way up
how did you got taken out of this long you try to short here because the only explanation that i can
have that you lost money is that you try to short to fade this movement to go back down
yes sellers are in control now we are still inside the area but sellers are controlling you see from
here let me clean this you can see from here that sellers are in controlling
control of the eye standing their ground reclaim of this
what is the best exercise to really understand pressure management when controlling a longer
short position sometimes i struggle with it hey it's just exercise mario there is uh
there is no shortcut on this
look look here
250 108 and huge speed of tape but candle red candle purple
you know that if it close like this and it close like this it's it's a problem for the buyers
the buyers they got completely absorbed
they got completely absorbed in this area crazy now they are trying to recover i want to see if they
can manage to close above because if i'm not wrong we are still
they are still in the buy area of the nasdaq efforts
yeah they are recovering buyers to control back
buyers to control back
no and no the effort is invalidated when you break it
it's uh you see the market tap into this area this is the area i think it's visible in colors but
this is the area it gets invalidated if it breaks
also this one no you have printed here
the mark test and reject
this one you print here the mac test don't break only weak and reject
so now why should be invalid i i was thinking that the next candle here
would be a breakout so they test and they they collapse but no they absorbed completely so still
the area is valid and buyers are still strong still we can go to the final target up
we saw we saw multiple entry technique so for example
let's see the trade-off before okay you have absorption here and you have buyers at the top
you have this breakout you can put a limit order this level
with a stop loss between this aggression and when you have another confirmation from the buyers you can
put your stop loss to zero like we did before now for the trades that we saw before was this one okay
you can enter with the stop loss below the area and put your stop loss at zero when you see this
and let's make another example let's say that you want to consider this trade okay
you get buyers that are controlling the auction okay and you can have for example speed of tape here
you can have your stop loss below the aggression of the buyers below the area for a risk to reward
i cannot see price but if we zoom in and we see here yeah it's correct this one should be
the area where you have the best entry so if we want to be precise now i don't know if we will get
filled but if we want to be really precise this one is should be the area and the stop loss should be
below here okay and you can see but it's only one to one no it's way more because we can go to this
target that it's a one two three point five it's an amazing trade okay it's limit so if you get filled
it's good which other execution method you can have let's say for example that now we break this okay
and we we break this with a buy candle strong and we see the market coming back printing
a candle like this here you can have another execution or the first execution with a stop loss below the
aggression of the sellers and the target above is it clear guys but i don't advise you to do this trade
i don't like it at all it's b setup c setup this one was triple a
one was really amazing okay
it filled
filled the area this is the area that is interesting
because it's the beginning of the candle with the complete control of the buyers
buy samuel thank you for your time
yeah at this point the session is done the the the major volatility of the day we had okay we had
amazing risk to reward anything you take from now it's to study it's not because this is a good setup
this is an average setup guys okay
thank you for the fantastic session thank you guys so i had some people already leaving the feedback
we went on for two hours and half i hope it's not too much i hope you can be able to
enjoy the session even if they are super long we had everything we had setups we had
best model to execute risk management now a lot of stuff is arriving for the next week and also the
weekend new section new participation to the group rules about advisory about supplements i take
files research paper to study and so on guys if you did a small profit i'm happy for you but this setup
is just
it's choppy now okay i think we can still go up a little bit but anyway look at the area look at the
precision of the area okay yeah they had the gap this one is the reloading gap when they are really aggressive
thank you guys thank you for everything have an amazing day i hope you are enjoying this service
ah someone have payout certificate 6000 peter amazing have a good day guys
it's playing i want to leave you but it's coming back the volatility from a one to ten how much score
you give to this even with low volatility it's a one to three from here to here
another gap look now now you don't you don't want to let us close you don't want to let us close
another gap here is true another gap they are building the pressure guys look what the they are doing
what an amazing session
no guys look at the comment of ud2 market needs to stop i want to take a
guys i think this is the best good weekend to you all that i can give you
low volatility environment another one to 100 i don't know how much is it
i think probably can go also here amazing session
nice guys bye now bye for real